when you look at the force billionaire
list almost all the men made their money
in tech
and then you have a man named bernard or
no at number three with around 170
billion dollars trailing right behind
elon musk and jeff bezos
and often trading places with them
except bernard didn't make his fortune
in tech he didn't make his fortune in
finance like warren buffett or with some
industrial conglomerate like the indian
billionaire at number 10
mukesh ambani now bernard made his
billions in the world of luxury
everything from fashion leather goods
jewelry and high-end spirits
he's the man behind the parent company
that owns some of the biggest names in
luxury
louis vuitton dua celine hennessey
tiffany and co tag heuer who blows
sephora and many more
making him the only top 10 billionaire
in luxury the richest man in europe one
of only four people right now in the
elusive centre millionaires club those
were over 100 billion and in two
instances bernard became the richest man
in the world for a few hours as his
company stock rose and fell
louis vuitton is by far the largest and
number one
luxury brand in the world in 2020 his
parent company lvmh made over 10.1
billion in profits
that means he's minting 1.1 million
dollars every hour or 19 000
every single minute by the time you're
done watching this video he would have
made around 285 000
during bernard's rise to the top of the
luxury world he was so ruthless that he
earned the nickname the wolf in cashmere
today forbes calls him one of the
world's ultimate taste makers
we're dealing with one of the most
successful people in the world one of
the great
taste makers in the world so what does
it take for a man to rise to the top of
the world in a single generation
this is the rise and reign of the wolf
and cashmere
[Applause]
the title animation you're seeing right
now was made using a plug and play
template from storyblocks today's
video's sponsor
storyblocks is a platform that lets you
download unlimited stock video
audio music images all in one single
affordable subscription
basically storyblocks gives you
everything you need to make videos
faster so you can get the views clicks
and shares you want without paying per
download
so making pro level edits like this
[Music]
is as easy as clicking download and if
you're new to video editing and you're
intimidated by it storyblocks even
offers an easy-to-use video editor that
lets you import the library directly
into your edit and export your videos
into all the popular formats
get started by going to
storyblocks.comtrain right now with the
link below to sign up for their
unlimited all-access plan
there's no commitment and you can cancel
at any time that's storyblocks.com jake
tran with the link below
[Music]
the 340 billion dollar business of
luxury is extremely different from any
other business out there like tech
[Music]
with something like facebook or google
your aim is to build something genuinely
useful that you charge little or no
money for for the masses to use
you're playing the game of keeping the
masses attention and we have an entire
video on modern tech monopolies if you
want to learn more
but in luxury the stuff you're selling
is not really useful there's not that
much practical value in a 55 000 piece
of metal with shiny rocks on it also
known as an ice dot watch
now don't get me wrong i love watches
but still there's not that much
practical value in the 3 000
louis vuitton purse or a 600 000 lambo
and yet these luxury brands are still
able to convince reasonable intelligent
people to be excited to give them their
money every single day
here's how it works
[Music]
the world is ran by smart people if you
look at the totem pole of society it's
just smart person on top of smart person
trying to convince other people to do
what they want them to do
give me your money and give me your time
give me your power your vote in exchange
for a product a job a handout and so
forth
when you're poor and broke you are owned
by smart people like your boss
smart people can get broke people to do
whatever they want because they're
broken desperate
your boss gives you money in exchange
for your time and you gladly take it
and there's nothing inherently morally
wrong about this it just is what it is
but then some people are able to make it
out of that poor face into the freedom
phase where you're making around 100k a
year or more on your own
at this point you're not owned by your
boss you don't have to rely on smart
people because you're not desperate
anymore
you're self-reliant you can do what you
want when you want etc at this point
smart people can no longer get at you
but they still really want to because
we're naturally power hungry creatures
so in order for smart people to convince
successful people to do what they want
them to do
you have to lure them in with something
else and that something else is luxury
goods
in order to get successful people to do
what they want they have to lure them
into something else
and the way they do this is with gold
gems and coins and
fancy things how do you get a person
that you can't control to give you all
their power
well you convince them you have
something that's worthwhile and valuable
you show off the watches the jewelry the
fashion and say this is what success
looks like but in order to look
successful you have to give me your
money for it
you see people buying 400 000 cars
getting giant houses you see people
flying private and showing off their
watches
these things have no value i mean
seriously they have no value
go get one go go get a 45 000 rolex see
how long it keeps you happy
you have this really smart chimpanzee in
the corner who sees that you have this
nuclear power core
that's super valuable which is your time
your energy and your focus
and your ability to generate power and
money says how can i get that
and so what he does is he goes and finds
some shiny rocks and he goes and finds a
banana and covers the banana
and shiny rocks and then waves it and
then walks around the room saying oh man
this is all
and then all the other all the other
chimpanzees go oh that's that's what
success looks like
you can probably see this in the likes
and people talking about it and people
going
and obsessing over cars and stuff on the
internet you know that's what success
looks like then the monkey goes oh no no
you can i don't
i've worked really hard to get this this
is this is so this is so
incredible and then all of a sudden you
go from being broke and working for
smart people to being free and
successful to then slowly getting lured
back into working for smart people
and so what slowly happens if smart
people get back in your life and they
take control of you again through the
banks
finances credit cards basically any way
they can
you get this big house you get all these
cars you get all this stuff and oh no
you gotta you gotta pay the lawn service
oh you gotta pay the pool guy
and then you got to you got to maintain
the house and you all you got to pay
your property taxes the bank needs some
extra
closing costs and suddenly you get
killed by a thousand
cuts and what's going to happen is smart
people start going and taking
your power all over again except when
you're a club at least you knew that you
were working for the smart people the
transaction was obvious it was a job you
gave me your time for money
on the other hand working for smart
people because they're waving a diamond
cover carrot in your face while at the
same time thinking that you're free and
successful
is a lot sneakier but leads to the same
results instead of you
ending up working for them because you
have no choice you end up voluntarily
working for smart people again sure you
can make two million dollars a year but
you just became
a two million dollar asset for all the
companies and all the things that you're
paying for that's all you are you're a
sucker
you're even worse than the guy who's
broke you start digging and digging and
digging because you think that's what
success is
and that's what all that's what stupid
people think success is if you go look
at uh what people are following on
instagram and youtube
that's what success looks like it's
having 15 lamborghinis three homes 14
different things but then
what happens is you add all these things
and because they don't really have any
value
well first off your life doesn't improve
but then what happens is you had a
hundred percent of your time and focus
right here to work on whatever you want
whenever you choose
you start having to worry about all
sorts of things
that really have nothing to do with your
happiness and suddenly you end up
working for all the objects that you own
and then what happens is you slowly end
up losing this freedom you achieved and
you're right back here
just in a far funnier way this is the
business of luxury you're not selling
practicality but the feeling of being
successful
the feeling that you're special higher
class above the other clubs that can't
afford this one and a half million
dollar watch
you're tapping into our instinctual
human desire for peacocking
to exhibit ourselves as christian dora
calls it the father of modern fashion
[Music]
the act of adorning ourselves with
luxury to show that we're different from
the have-nots dates back as far as
ancient
huh oh egypt 18 million 18 million 18
million
oh you know now again there's nothing
wrong with this i'm into luxury goods
but if you do get into it you just have
to know that this is the game you're
paying into
alex becker has a great video on this
that i will link below
i'm not saying don't buy nice things for
your family i'm saying just realize the
cost they're going to come at
because they do have cost money is a
form of power just like your energy and
focus
and the thing is when you get lured in
by smart people when you start going and
getting lots of things
that energy and focus gets sucked away
and your power
also gets sucked away the most important
thing you should think when you're
buying things is just realize first off
every expensive thing comes with major
major major time constraints and that's
where our guy bernard arno comes in
[Music]
bernard grew up as the son of a father
who owned a manufacturing and civil
engineering company in france
according to bernard his mom made two
major contributions to his life
one she made him take piano lessons
something that he still plays today
and two she had a fascination with the
perfume and fashion brand christian doa
little did she know that one day her son
would own the company bernard graduated
as an engineer from france's most
prestigious engineering school and then
he joined his father's company
his father was the one that really gave
him a sense of business and by age 25
he took over the reigns of his dad's
company with the ambitions of starting
his own empire
and my father was really exceptional
because
he always gave me the sense of business
he then sell off the construction side
of the business and went into real
estate in 1976
and by 1981 as the french socialist rose
and threatened to attack the rich
bernard moved his family to america
where he would spend the next
three years growing his family's real
estate business when he returned to
france in 1983
he started looking for undervalued deals
in business and came across something
that i couldn't pass up
it was christiandor
[Music]
see in the 80s everyone was getting
richer the world was becoming more of a
meritocracy than ever before
climbing the social ladder in america
was easier than ever before
this made for a welfare middle class
disposable income went up people were
getting married later in life so they
had more money to spend on themselves
the average consumer was more educated
and developed a taste for the finer
things in life
and out emerged the new social class of
the affluent unmarried female with
plenty of money to spend or in other
words there was a whole new demographic
of customers to sell high-margin luxury
goods to
and it was happening right before
bernard's eyes what we can call the
democratization of luxury
and there was a lot of money to be made
we try to
build a large business with our partners
with one criteria the best quality
and the most elitist product
in every line that we are selling
throughout the world so he bought the
parent company at one door and proceeded
to sell off the majority of their other
businesses so he was only left with a
few including doa and he quickly turned
it into a success
by 1987 a company called moet tennessee
was merging with louis vuitton to form
the conglomerate lvmh
moa tennessee owned the brands moita
shindon champin and hennessy kanyak
bernard saw this merger taking place and
he had a golden idea that he had to move
on
the creation of a luxury group that
owned a ton of different luxury brands
at the idea of a luxury group
now looking back to where we are now
this trend of the world moving towards
luxury is really easy to see but at the
time
not so much and everyone probably
thought bernard was crazy to dump
everything him and his father built to
go into an industry that he had zero
experience in
like what you're gonna give up
everything to sell overpriced nice to
have products to people who have zero
history of buying these things
it was a big risk so he started
investing in lvmh upping his stake to
become the largest shareholder
spending upwards of 600 million dollars
a week to increase his holdings
this will begin one of the fiercest
battles in french fashion history
he was a complete visionary he saw
things that nobody else
saw he saw the increase of wealth in the
world
[Music]
on september 15 1988 the french
industrialist announced that he had
become the largest shareholder of lvmh
at 37
he then started to fillet many of the
company's loyal servants with the goal
of ousting the former chairman and many
of the top executives
in the end he came out on top and earned
the nickname the wolf in cashmere
for his ruthlessness that will be a mage
at the time on louis vuitton obviously
a bunch of alcohol brands javinci
perfume christian lacroix and a few
other brands as well
but bernard wanted more he wanted to
capitalize on this democratization of
luxury as much as possible
so he started buying up everything
belluti in 1993
celine in 1996 mark jacobs and sephora
in 1997 tagged hero and gucci in 1999
fendi dkny nrms which later fell through
in 2001
bulgari in 2011 and most recently
tiffany and co in 2020 for a staggering
15.8 billion dollars
and these are just some of the
acquisitions bernard arno
is the most talked about man in the
fashion world today itself does over one
billion dollars a year i understood that
something was going on you know when you
start seeing your
your father's face on tv and in the
newspapers
it's one thing to identify a moment in
time
and to have your taste and your vision
collide with what the world would want
at that moment in time
but he's been successful over a lot of
moments
over a very long period of time across
the world
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
today lvmh owns 75 luxury brands they
just swallowed up nestle pushing them to
become the most valuable company in
europe
and the 21st most valuable company in
the world they own hotels around the
world and their entire empire can be
divided into six branches
fashion wine and spirits perfume and
cosmetics watches and jewelry selective
distribution and other activities
the wolf in cashmere is also living
large he lives in a 150 year old castle
in france with a bunch of other
properties in france
he has five different homes in beverly
hills california he owns a 150 million
dollar super yacht named the symphony
worth more than all his beverly hills
homes combined he's got a 40 million
dollar private jet
he reportedly owns his own private
island in the bahamas called the indigo
and of course he's a bit of an art
collector with his own museum called
defund
luis and at 72 years old bernard arnold
shows no signs of slowing down
to have the empire he has based upon
talent and good management skills but
with very creative people who themselves
probably think they're the best in the
world what they do
and in many cases they're right and
somehow he's able to
get those people to work collaboratively
and organize them
and work for him that's not at all how
he thinks in my opinion i think his
big strength is actually to speak to
creative people
and to make them thrive under his
management
it's not to create profit or create more
revenue or double the size of the
business
you know the success of the group is
made of the quality of the product and
the quality of the product
is a consequence of the extraordinary
craft men and women
that are working with us guys don't
forget to check out storyblocks the
sponsor of today's video where you can
get unlimited video
audio music pictures after effects
animations
everything you need to make videos
faster storyblocks has them with the
link below
these sponsors really help make this
channel possible so you should check
them out and support them and you get a
great product in return
i will admit that i've been getting more
and more into luxury products as the
days go on especially watches like this
beautiful
young hans world timer in rose gold my
favorite color i got this from a youtube
friend that does watch videos his name
is teddy balastar he runs on a watch
channel and he has his own authorized
dealership that i got this from
super nice i really like it you can
check it out with the link below not
sponsored i don't get any kickback
cool guy i am well aware of the game
that i'm buying into but
my plan is to just indulge and you know
get out of my system and then if and
when
i realize that this stuff is a total
waste of money i will move on with my
life
if you're new here you might also
subscribe because we make video essays
just like this one and that one every
single week
on the most thought-provoking stuff in
the world of business shout out to
athena for following me on instagram i
am following that one random person
every single week
at jaketrend.io that is gonna wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you